welcome hey what's going on eric
bischoff Bruce Prichard same room sit
down guys welcome to the show I want you
guys to know - did you see The Miz on
the way out yes he was furious because
this morning I got a text that he was in
town can the men's come on but I was
like of course miss can come on anytime
he wants and I said but I got Bruce and
and Bischoff coming in at 9:45 so it's
gonna have to be before 9:45 and he was
very upset that he had to reschedule
everything and go into his break time to
make sure that you guys got your time as
well pre-madonna
yeah yeah well welcome guys it's a it's
kind of amazing seeing you guys in the
in the same room promoting promoting the
same project now huh
did you realize I mean in 2018 so last
night so I was talking about at the
beginning of the show Bruce Prichard has
has done things that I don't think
anybody expected him to do including you
yourself Bruce in the centrally me yeah
you kind of turned podcasting especially
wrestling podcasting upside down in the
sense that you come out with this
podcast where you know you're a known
guy you know people know brother love
but in general the name Bruce Prichard
like hardcore wrestling fans know who
Bruce Prichard is but you're not like a
household name per se and depends on
which household yeah I guess in my
household you were known well let's see
there you go
but you come out with this podcast and
it's just Bruce Prichard telling his
stories of 20 years of being right next
to Vince McMahon right and going through
shows and and specific characters and
all this stuff and it catches fire to
the extent that you're doing like
hundreds of thousands of podcast
downloads well first of all I lived
through the time being next to Vince
McMahon for all those years yeah that's
the biggest shock and the fact that
anyone cares to hear those stories and
yeah I'm amazing in and of itself as
well wait I think what's really amazing
and and you guys are both in the same
boat is that you guys come from this
time when wrestling was South Park right
like wrestling was the biggest thing in
the world so the stories that you have
from that five years or something all
those people that were watching even if
they're not watching current day WWE
necessarily they still care about all
those stories from when they were
growing up you know the my favorite
thing is when people ask me the first
thing out of their mouth is what
happened when and then they fill in the
blank but almost all of the
conversations start off with hate what
happened what happened when you remember
that guy the one with the black hair and
he was built really okay describe half
the roster let's get a little more
specific
but it's interesting now because Bruce
you were you were one of Vince's
right-hand men for like 20 years right
right and a big part of that was the
time when Eric Bischoff over here was
running WCW in a specifically as
competitive as anybody has ever run a
company going right after WWE to the
point where you and Vince McMahon are
writing TV competing with what Eric is
doing and Eric is a great MTV competing
with what you're doing and it got to the
point where you guys were after each
other's throats right I was after the
audience I didn't give a damn about
their throats but the audience was
really important you didn't did you just
want the audience or did you
specifically want the audience to the
point where like they were gonna be out
of business no I think you know that's
kind of a false narrative you know that
kind of exploded out of that area out of
that era and a lot of that had to do
with the fact that you know Vince
McMahon tried to convince everybody that
big bad billionaire Ted was trying to
put him out of business he was trying to
make himself the babyface he was trying
to galvanize the loyalty in his brand it
had been around for a long long time
that really wasn't the case there was no
real you know agenda to put anybody out
of business but there was a big agenda
in terms of being number one and and
willing to do whatever it took to become
number one so that story that's been
told of you rallying your troops and
saying we're going to put WWE out of
business or WF at the time it's
happening we're putting them out of
business that's not something you did
you know I probably did and I know that
sounds like I'm contradicting myself but
there was a lot of things that I did
said back then to rally my troops as
well because he can't remember from a
talents point of view it was a very
weird situation
I had a roster full of talent that I was
asking to do things that they knew was
going to probably burn a bridge like
what kind of stuff
oh just anything that I could do to
embarrass kind of put down the
competition you know it was one thing
for me to go out and give away finishes
and one one thing for me to go out with
a holding a sign that says Vince McMahon
fears ratings that was me I had no
intention of ever needing to go back or
going back to going to WWE the talent on
the other hand the intention of you
coming to WWE of course but the talent
knew better the talent knew that there
was only really two places to work they
were either working for me are they
working for WWE and they didn't want to
do a lot of the stuff that I asked them
to do that took it over took it to the
top Travis we have another guest who's
downstairs can you help get them up
maybe I'll notice thanks man
yeah do you still have the producers
number that I texted you Bruce can you
text him the name that you want in the
system we'll put it in the system we'll
get him up
so you didn't so that it was more
creating this sort of it was your
bravado kind of trying to be infused
into your talent it was a couple of
things
it was galvanizing the troops yeah
getting everybody to believe in the fact
that we could be number one and stay
number one it was probably a little bit
of my ego sure no doubt about that you
know I had one I was very still I'm a
very competitive person so I probably
got caught up and a lot of my own BS in
that regard but I can assure you there
was no real agenda about putting anybody
out of business I knew even back then
Sam that the best environment we could
be in was a competitive environment it
was like the Coke and Pepsi Wars which
is kind of what I modeled you know my
approach to the business after right
right and I mean it does make sensing is
something people have talked about that
the best time for both companies has
been when there's fierce fierce fierce
competition and Bruce you as somebody
that was there before there was
competition that was this bad while and
after
you think the best time was when there
was really without a doubt when there's
somebody look you find a lot harder when
you're getting your ass kicked and when
Eric came in at WCW when they really got
competitive and they came after us with
a vengeance and all of a sudden we
weren't the only game in town we were
the ones now that were just fighting for
that existence and fighting to be a part
of everything and they're doing great
numbers which made us do better numbers
the business got healthier as a whole
and I think that's what's missing today
is some good healthy competition but a
lot of that's in hindsight like while
it's happening do you think that like
holy [ __ ] we might be going out of
business here there were there were
times that we thought oh man you know
could this be it but at the same time
having been through similar situations
you always know that there's gonna be a
light at the end of the tunnel if you
keep working and you keep fighting for
it but there were definitely times when
we thought oh man we're gonna shut the
doors and this is all over like when
they were taken to water coolers out of
the building in that kind of stuff no it
was it was more when we were flying down
to buy WCW and did you have to take
water coolers I mean was there dude
finances we shaved expenses we did what
we had to do to survive and then come
back and conquer that's what he
ultimately did was it tough to be
financially disciplined because that's
the other narrative right that you were
not financially disciplined because you
had Ted Turner's money and that you
could just you know again the narrative
is you could just offer big talent
however much money in the world they
wanted in these ridiculous deals that
nobody could possibly maintain for any
amount of time yeah it's all BS right
not true at all so the thing that the
one thing that I always think that Eric
did was when people say that basically
what he did was create an atmosphere
that had never been created for the
wrestling business before where all of a
sudden the competition for contracts and
the competition for their compensation
and that changed everything and I and
it's changed even to this day the way
that we had done
business in the past so did you have any
what were your feelings about Eric
Bischoff haters Cup you didn't even know
him as appreciate his guts didn't even
know him right and and like did you have
when you met him the first time when you
meet him the first time the first day
well the first time I met him so when he
came in for an interview with us in 1991
yeah 1991 and then that will you not get
that I didn't get the game no but anyway
but the the next time is when he came in
in the Meadowlands over in New Jersey
when WC have you guys had a business and
Eric Bischoff becomes a character on WWE
raw general manager so is that as by
then how many years removed from WCW was
that moment I had I had really left WCW
for all intents and purposes in 98 I
came back for a short period of time for
about six months or a year taken out 500
mm so I had been out of it I think was
2002 when I came to WWE so I had been
out of the business out of the public
eye for about two years so it's two
years enough time for your feelings of
hatred and animosity to kind of go away
or when you see this guy are you like I
don't know if we should be bringing this
dude in no actually I was one of the
people that want him to bring him in
really and and again you have to
understand that when I say I hated his
guts I hated losing right okay so once
your winning yeah once I'm winning all
hey Eric I'm sure he's a great guy but
again you talk about people that you've
never met before that you've never been
around and you judged them based on the
outside perception which is not always
fair once I met him you know I fell in
love with him and he's one of my best
friends today but it was you know not I
think if we had met in different
circumstances you know might have been
different
yeah like like if we'd have met in a bar
in 1998 down in Houston or something
really I'm three-time Hall of Fame like
all the Hall of Fame just saying I've
heard that yeah do you think because
there were I mean Eric you kind of
notoriously challenged Vince McMahon to
a fight on your pay-per-view
are you feel hey John rest up what's
going on JBL of course how are you
welcome standing yeah welcome welcome to
the show man I just thought I'd crash
the party
I'm glad you gentlemen were here we're
here because we're at Barclays Center
tonight for the something to Russell
with live to plug box of gimmicks calm
for tickets it's gonna be our special
guest we would love to have you join us
as well in your fancy little outfit you
got on today you look good it's not a
fancy little Sam look at this outfit is
this not just I mean looks great but
he's a big man he is a big man but he
looks like the number three ball look
like Daddy Warbucks with that $18,000
Kustoms coat you got on over your
$10,000 suit and your what do you got on
what kind of boots you got off
he's got alligator boots on I got
ostrich okay oh yeah my mine
miner like 20 years old his he just
killed that alligator the other day I
got Jordans there you go there it is so
it is the three-ball in it that's red we
do we do we were just talking about the
rivalry that existed between these two
and obviously I mean JBL you were like a
soldier I feel like in in the wrestling
Wars for a long time like you've been a
WWE loyalist cuz Bischoff did want me
but like so you're saying we're talking
about the night that Eric Bischoff
challenge for me into a fight on his
pay-per-view which it wasn't a wrestling
match it would've been a fight it was
the idea I think would have been no
wrestling match no I think we've pretty
right who's leading like I think we've
established that a should they have met
at a bar that Bruce may not have fared
well against Eric because he's a karate
that's kind of what world knows it it's
okay a ton of money to the Hall of Fame
freakin three-time wall of fame a second
Bruce Lee I don't think he was inducted
that many times you know did you ever
have fantasies or thoughts of beating up
Eric Bischoff it during any of those
days no absolutely not
we had a very friendly rivalry we did at
the time when they invaded Norfolk I
guess it was we were at the rock their
clothes and we invaded we invaded from
Norfolk what yeah yeah tonight we didn't
know what would happen back because we
invaded in that afternoon you're alive
and people went around Gerry Briscoe
went around and told her by the kind of
weight on the park about just could we
know what would happen right so you know
Harry boys out there you had Ken
Shamrock which we're kind of hoping that
Ken Shamrock would just was about all we
needed really yeah yeah that was the
night that I or the the afternoon WWE
sends their guys over to where we were
open Ken Shamrock and Haku would get
into a fight because it was promised it
would probably still be going we could
just watch right but actually you say
you guys were stationed all around the
parking lot just to seek who we had no
idea what was gonna happen I sure it was
a crazy time well until until the show
was over and Vinson them actually left
la arena because we don't think comm
tried to reciprocate in some way did you
know that there were people Eric station
just in case you sent troops over no I
mean I had no idea any of that was going
on and that's one of the things that I
regret the most because had I known I
would have left them in had I known what
ever would have happened would have
happened on television and it would have
been so much just go call the bluff Oh
called the bluff yeah I mean anybody
that knows me and if you just look back
at the way I did things back then in
terms of television I think that would
have been some of the greatest
television in the history of wrestling
so we're talking about when when
DX from the WWE went over to nitro and
and and was like outside in the parking
lot and threatening to come in they were
driving a tag and they were had no plan
no I mean I had know a little bit about
you did I were there right oh yeah I was
there directing the whole thing you had
a dummy tape though a dummy tape that
occasionally they've got kidnapped you
were gonna sneak one out that was
something yeah you actually had a plan
but we if you got the build notes they
Eric or to let you in
if you got the building what would you
have done oh god we just would have
taped it and gone for we were kind of
home they were hoping we were hoping for
the bravado we were hoping we were gonna
get in and get something but you know
what yeah honestly I don't think what
you would have gotten would have been
worse yeah you're right because the the
boys there was no heat between a boy
right no they would have broke it in
they would have come in they would have
been all in character you know George
would have been kicked down there but he
got to ring it up and high-five at each
other and you know having a good time
let's go crack a beer so it would have
killed the whole thing I think so I
agree completely so that's the way you
felt about the ww oh we had no animosity
toward those guys right they were trying
to put us out of business when and we
were trying to stay alive you know you
know there was a professional fight
between us but there was no animosity
between us personally you are all part
of the same fraternity absolutely Rob
everybody's trying to make a living the
boys are trying to make a living and you
don't want to put your buddy out of work
so but it is interesting because before
you came in Erik was just saying that he
did not want to put you guys out of
business that that was something that
the Vince McMahon that was that was a
narrative that kind of Vince McMahon was
more pushing to get you guys all charged
up okay well you know whatever the no
mokou what are the narrative it worked
yeah you know there that time we weren't
selling any tickets before right before
that business was horrible business was
horrible at WCW as well then all sudden
the NWO goes over there and and sparks
this incredible rise and and also the
business starts getting better and we're
getting beaten for the first time and
that was a scary thought you know we
knew that Ted Turner had deep pockets we
knew that we were a private company we
had to stay within budget it was it was
a scary fight that we had because it was
not an asymmetrical fight at that point
right all of a sudden this thing well
anyway it wasn't a smart option it had
been off balance the other way before
that right like w7u wasn't looked at as
real competition for WWF before any of
this it was just like that's just that
stuff that's going on down south over
there and then all of a sudden it gets
injected and now it's like now WCW is
the one and I honestly not to jump in
John but I can imagine being on the WWE
side of the equation they're competing
against WCW who was owned by Turner
Broadcasting who owned a plethora of
network security at T and TBS
had unlimited funds you know that was a
that was a tough animal to go
head-to-head with quite honestly when
you were not a public with public
company at that time right you don't own
your own networks your programming is on
the air at the behest of you know
network executives who couldn't change
their mind in their direction you know
at the spur of the moment so it wasn't
necessarily a fair situation either but
that whole thing that was your advantage
then is what ended up screwing up that
besides you completely because the
company got even bigger and when you're
in that corporate structure like you
guys have the opportunity to kind of do
whatever you want cuz it's your company
that's true and I think the other thing
that people forget a lot of times is WCW
for so many years had a history of
having old wrestling promoters who were
in charge of things very easy you could
tell what the game plan was you kind of
knew what it was you figured it out
ahead of time now of a sudden you got
this new young cocky kid who wants to be
in the television business and he's
doing things that traditionally had
never been done in our business before
so the rules of the game which there are
no rules to the game where all of a
sudden being changed and we're going oh
well
dusty never would have done that Bill
Watts never would have done that boss
never would have done that
well Eric Bischoff did it yeah and it
works which is interesting because when
you look at how WWF was first on that
rise all the other promoters were saying
Vince McMahon's not playing by the rules
that's not what we do it is ironic you
came and everybody who's like played by
these new established rules it's like
what's he doing you can't do that stuff
you can't give away our results and Ted
Turner was different then I mean it said
turn a little bit of Luster's would come
off since you stepped down from CNN but
that time he was on top of the world you
know he had the Braves he had a new
format with it with the Braves with his
new TV network we're now he's not only
you know it's the DES Network now with
the Yankees but Ted Turner was one who
started all that he was on top of the TV
world at that time it was a scary thing
to be in a fight with Ted Turner how he
really was he was an entrepreneurs
entrepreneur and probably the last of a
dying breed in that respect at least at
his level and he was willing to take
amazing chances he was a risk-taker yeah
is it tough when you get to work with a
guy like that because I really see you
at admiration for him is it tough to
then kind of try to figure out
the next thing is without because you're
gonna look at all people of that caliber
as and you could be Ted Turner right and
you're just not doing that it was in
fact I never really did adjust you know
the corporate environments never been
one that I've been able to adjust to
since that time for that very reason
because I loved working for someone that
was a risk taker he held you accountable
it wasn't you know as we talked about
earlier the narrative just here's a
bunch of money kid go do whatever you
need to do that wasn't the case at all I
had to live within guidelines and
budgets and all the holes and the same
things everybody don't have result and
that was measured against those and what
I succeeded I was given more rope and
that kind of thing but to be able to
have the opportunity to work with a guy
like Ted Turner who was a visionary in
every way CNN is here cable news lives
today as a result of Ted Turner's vision
in execution right that was an amazing
time and I miss it so you know I think
Eric's rise is one of the greatest TV
stories in history really I mean yeah
there's no doubt about it he goes from
this regional territory up in the old
AWA to be running with this company that
was beating WWE soundly for almost three
years yeah the revenue jumps is
significant multiple which is by the way
fairly unheard of because you can talk
about this like its history but even
then WWF is what it was then and that
was the name synonymous with Pro
Wrestling you didn't say Pro Wrestling
he said WWF so the idea the WCW then
could come and beat them in the ratings
every week for years is as ludicrous as
somebody doing it now yeah and no person
does it single-handedly but Eric deserve
some majority of the the credit for all
of this this was an incredible story in
television that happened in an
incredible time do you think it's enough
credit for being a television story not
just a wrestling story because I really
think I can you imagine an upstart
league coming along and unseating the
NFL
yeah and beating them and almost putting
them out of business for years for years
yeah that's pretty it's absolutely
unheard of yeah and then and then a
Shakespearean fall you know right which
hits it's an incredible story right now
when it fell Eric when WCW fell had you
kind of washed her hands with it so it
was like I'm not really upset about
what's happened to this place or did it
feel like your baby was kind of being
pulled from
little bit of both you know I really it
didn't happen all at once you know it
probably looked like it did in many
respects to the audience but in my world
it really started in about the in August
of 98 when the AOL Time Warner would
that really begin to manifest and the
changes that came along with it started
really setting in the handwriting was on
the wall what that merger worked out
well didn't it yes but it was it was a
painful period for like 98 August of 98
until the you know the time I was sent
home in September of 99 was probably the
worst year in my life to be honest with
you and then when it finally you know
when WCW was purchased by WWE and it was
official you know one half of my brain
was so very much you know I felt like it
was my baby as you said the other half
of my brain was doing everything I could
to try to just separate myself from it
and move on with my life so I mean it
got to it just a crazy point like we all
we all can imagine that wrestlers were
being traded back and forth and you know
oh he's popping up here he's popping up
there but it got to the place where
off-screen people writers were being
traded back and forth and stuff like
that was happening was there ever a
moment where you were like let's see if
we can get Bruce from Vince know that
you know that's that's another you know
part of the narrow narrative there was
never really anybody that we set back
you know you know in a dark room with a
couple of six-packs and said okay let's
see if we could get this guy let's try
to steal this guy that never happened
when talent whether it was writers or
producers or whomever came over to WCW
it was really them coming to us it
wasn't us trying to cherry-pick Talent
the only person that I kind of coveted
and I didn't even know him at the time
was Pat Patterson because there were so
many people that were working for me
that had worked with Pat and obviously
worked with Vince McMahon
that they just kept telling me what a
great finish guy Pat Patterson was and I
had never worked with him when I had
never met him but I but I knew looking
at our product in what was lacking in
our product that I needed somebody with
that kind of depth of storytelling
ability and that it's a headline out of
that is Eric Bischoff wanted Pat
Patterson did not want Bruce price
thinking like who we wanted but we know
we know we won't Bruce so that was we
wanted that was the only name that ever
came up and that was really because I
didn't know inside where it counts it
hurts
no what you did at that time I was just
it didn't come up really okay if now
that you know I would have been over pad
don't talk to Kevin Nash huh yeah well
because it came over never mention your
name it's their fault I never mentioned
your name
wow I just didn't damn I unbelievable
they never even mention your name all I
did talk about Pat how about a field a
field they mentioned lay fields name
really actually I tried to court him in
an airport in Tokyo one time and make a
deal with him but it never happened away
raised bar into Rita Airport Attitude
Era start at 98 Gold does first came out
as goldust were covered in the crazy
stuff I don't remember cuz when I was on
a five-week tour for Bob at the point
but I had to fulfill an obligation to go
back was Barry Windham and we were part
of the tag team tournament and I run
into Eric leaving the leaving the Japan
and he got back and I was in the middle
of a contract negotiation got me a huge
razor and they once offered me a job so
it was a terrific that's at least buy
you a beer no I I bought everything no I
don't actually I don't remember he was
it was very nice it was a great
conversation first time I never met him
great timing for that conversation to
happen though somebody just happened to
see it they thought it was a clandestine
meeting yeah we would all the was so hot
we knew we couldn't meet in Des Moines
we agree to meet Sookie I know what from
I guess from a talent perspective what
was your interactions with Bruce print I
love Pat is my show tonight over
Barclays Center function
gonna be there you better pack that
there tonight for many years of Indian
birthday historic today hey Pat Pat's
birthday today 77 years old historically
for many years Vince McMahon had Bruce
Prichard and Pat Patterson by his side
helping him with a lot of the apparently
only one bad it was mainly Pat was just
there for like comic relief I guess no I
know I hired Bradshaw what was your
Voyageur since he's here because I'm
gonna ask you about Eric - but what was
your favorite thing that you did with
Bradshaw from a creative perspective we
went to one time when we first started
the JBL character and was working a
program with Eddie Guerrero so we went
to Athens Texas to shoot some vignettes
John catching some illegals jumping over
a fence if we'd only know how to wall
that would have been better but then
again it would have been 2018 as well
but we did it in Athens where John is
and we get to this house that John has
set up for us of this ranch land and we
have crew and I got lighting people and
they're walking all around the house the
people aren't home yet and there's
shining lights in their house looking
around and starting to set up stuff and
a truck comes pulling down the driveway
long driveway because it's in Athens
Texas were lay fields from nothing but
rich people there so as the truck comes
down we're like hey this must be them
and the guy stops and we see him get out
of his truck go in the back of his truck
and look like he got a shotgun or
something comes back in and we're sit
there hey how you doing and the guy
comes out and who are you we were at the
wrong house oh boy that could've been if
we had waved to him yeah Wow
he thought it was being robbed and he
thought he pulled up on bunch people the
last thoughts looking at windows I mean
it was it looked like we were and we're
unloading things which looks like we're
loading things you're damn and but that
was a lot of fun that night just John
chasing a family of immigrants over back
over the gift bag
boy what an amazing what you used to be
able to get away with one character in
Carrigan character yeah and especially
you know and I think it's kind of
getting lost that there was a time when
like a skit like that right you could
show it with the explanation that this
is a villainous character so if you
don't like what he's doing in terms of
chasing and wiggles out of the country
if you don't like that that's fine cuz
he's a villain he's supposed to be doing
bad things right you know what's really
interesting even today you know rusty
has always fallen a sports entertainment
has always fallen into this kind of
weird grey Airy grey or Academy category
because in comedy you could still do
that today
sure in drama you could still do that
today right right in sports
entertainment you can't do that today
because it's viewed in a different
context by the audience do you think it
has to be viewed by that context or if
you were if you were running a promotion
or something would you try to focus more
on the fact that these are people
portraying characters here's the credits
at the end here's this guy's real name
the latter it is because otherwise you
become much more confined yeah terms of
your ability to tell a story and and to
solicit communes to get comedy you know
you have to be a little outrageous you
have to do outrageous things but when
you're viewed in this weird kind of gray
area context it makes it very very
difficult what do you think of that JBL
I think I completely agree I think it's
insane I mean he had Carolina Walking
Dead it's basically assassinated
exterminate some teenager one day a
green girl you know and people didn't
outraged that's too far bill fans
chanting that's too far
chanting that's too far really for what
yeah and I've never understood heel
sections you know if a heel has a heel
section he's not doing his job he or she
he's not doing his job and if people are
comfortable with the heel heat it's not
good heat right exactly you know and why
why is sports entertainment held to a
different standard than Walking Dead or
Game of Thrones or any other show like
in 2018 there should be Twitter outrage
over a bad guy wrestler because that's
how that's how people express not liking
something right you don't like a
character you say hey I don't like the
attributes of this character right or I
really love the attributes of this
character yeah
for it's interesting though that I mean
people don't like the eye but I think
maybe a great example years ago first
time I'd seen no what now is called the
smart walk I don't know what they they
still have that term now but I've never
I never met somebody who'd written for
one of the dirt sheets go back this back
in the early nineties and somebody told
I just think that work rate from killer
Tim Brooks is terrible first time I
heard that term work rate by the way so
you so the first time you hear the term
work rate is by one of the wrestling
gossip people that are trying to use
wrestling lingo that's right just never
worked and I said what do you mean he
said well he just can't work just killer
Jimbo can't work and I said well let me
ask you a question if they brought in
Stan Hanson to beat up killer Tim Brooks
would you pay he goes I'd pay double I
go here right he's not a work killer was
a great worker but you know that that to
me is sums up some of what you see with
the hardcore bass that's probably why
you get along with Eric and Fran
actually you would Bruce too and the way
we don't get along better than her share
of love for donkeys portrayed totally
you know whatever you want to be but
none of you guys have ever had a problem
with heat none of you guys have ever had
a problem being the villain none of you
guys have ever in fact if you feel I
think all three if you feel like you're
starting to get cool you're starting to
get cheered you'd go and do something
that pisses absolutely I walked out one
day and I saw a JBL shirt and I called
Vince right away and I said why are you
selling my shirts because I had no idea
we were and I said this kills me
Wow why would I you want to heal to sell
a shirt Randy he said you're right they
took it off to show off right away well
they know that but that person didn't
buy one they had spilled something on
and we gave them somebody in the stands
to be wearing some of your merchandise
they know this guy is cool and and
person next to wanting to boo you you
got to embrace that heat and there
aren't many people that do you
guy like Randy Orton does he certainly
loves it a guy like Miz does theirs yeah
Jericho does Jericho Jericho does a
terrific he'll that's a small handful
but it's a credibly small handful and
it's always been a small handful yeah
and I think it's getting smaller now
because the it's not just dealing with
the crowds its dealing with social media
it follows you now so you have to be
comfortable with people who don't sure
separate the person and the character
following you and me like you suck you
suck you suck remember when we had the
unamerican
and then they quit because they were
getting too much heat yeah real he
didn't want heat somebody called him a
bad name in the airport he said we can't
take this and they live in Tampa I'm not
a known American what are we doing here
okay Bruce this is probably pretty
obscure for you but for us like we all
remember do you remember when a guy a
comedian named Patrice O'Neal wrote for
you guys I think he lasted maybe three
days
he said Stephanie fired him four or five
times because he didn't have a
conversation about it she goes no you're
fired and he goes all right I'm firing
you right now yeah I heard you yeah he
was uh he got and he ended up he was a
huge wrestling fan yep hilarious
probably he couldn't go down as the one
of the great stand-ups of all time right
and and since he's passed away I think
that's only gone up up up and here's my
here's my Patrice story was in the very
short time that he was with ripening
because he ended up leaving because he
goes I got stand-up gigs this weekend
because I'm not gonna leave stand-up and
when when you got sign it was like yeah
that's fine keep doing your stand-up
thing and they go hey we need you
Saturday and he's like well I got a
stand-up gig and they're like well we
need you in he's like wow I got a
stand-up cake and that was it and then
he went to deuce Sunday night heat at
the world or the WWF New York and the
entire time was playing video games the
entire time I'm supposed to be there
help produce things he's just sitting in
the corner playing video games and
they're like where is Patrice and he was
nowhere to be found and then they go
back in the little arcade thing there
and he's you know in the same thing is I
can't be
now man I got the high score goal and
I'm gonna get this that's kind of yep
that's tells the end that's exactly
Patrice though yeah I mean that's
exactly what he would have done in that
scenario yeah I just curious so uh I'm
bummed at the gym isn't here he's in st.
Louis this weekend but that's because
Norton performs stand-up on the boat at
Shane McMahon's bachelor party well that
had to been I did not oh I did you were
there state of mind that he doesn't
remember if I was there must have been a
good party it was a hell of a party it
was a helluva it was it was it was it
was plugged and Pro Mode to me a hell of
a party so much so that we all had car
services from our home and we all took a
bus to the boat and I mean everybody
nobody was allowed to drive and just
show up you had to be on the bus you had
to have a car service so a lot of times
when parties get hyped up like that it
ends up you know nothing can live up to
the hype this wasn't one of this was a
lot of fun a lot of fun man this was
this was a good time do you have any
recollection of the stand-up comedy that
evening I don't remember the stand-up
comedy I remember the other
entertainment I had on the boat which
was a lot of fun right okay there was no
donkey so I was looking for JBL because
I figured he would know so we talked
about what your favorite thing with JBL
is I somebody tweeted me this actually
last night and they said if you got
Bruce and Eric in the same room please
ask them about the night on Smackdown
when Eric Bischoff passionately made out
with Stephanie McMahon and then it just
kind of was just that like it was just
that one moment and then that was the
end of it you I think did you produce
that I did what happened there I pretty
much just what you what you saw but if
you're okay with the here's the weird
thing to it and I'll never forget Bryan
the works because Eric was where
Vince McMahon mask right prior to that
it was a Halloween episode and and Brian
kept going us is it not funny to anybody
else that like technically she's making
out with her dad well her dad is
standing four feet away by the way is
that for you Eric is it when you okay
when you first get tasked with this when
you find out tonight on the show you're
gonna make out with Stephanie what's the
first thought it was a rib you didn't
think was gonna have anything it was
real did you get along with Stephanie
professionally yeah not personally right
not that we didn't get along personally
but I didn't interact with her on a
personal level professionally we got
along fine
so what point do you find out that it's
real wise this is happening when Bruce
started work walking me through it I
started setting it up and staging it you
know finding our marks can at me like
we're gonna really kiss and and Vince is
standing there you know directing you
know watching this whole thing wow this
is bizarre how is Vince that has had his
Vince direct I probably shouldn't be
here you the point of this story is that
Vince is a great leader and a motivator
that's all I'm trying to get across but
was it a as it was in an awkward
scenario for you or once it's like once
you're once you're doing something in
that world it's just whatever we're
doing you know I went to WWE knowing
that I was gonna be put in situations
that were awkward and uncomfortable
because that's the nature you know if
you look at Vince McMahon some of the
things awkward situations he's put
himself in yeah where he's put his
daughter in or he's put other people in
I knew when I stepped into that
environment I was gonna be put into
situations like that once I knew that it
was real and it wasn't a rib to me it's
it was honestly it was just another
scene I didn't really think about it too
much you know the best thing I'm Vince
was when he was with Stone Cold Steve
Austin so about Vince
himself in embarrassing situations where
he used the bathroom on himself in the
ring as some and Suzie did Ron Simmons
turn amigos now what are you gonna say
no to put over Steve and to be you know
the ultimate bad guy coward yeah you
know what are you saying no to which at
that point does it feel good as a talent
to know like you know what the boss is
in this with us like we're all doing
this it's a work yeah do something he
wouldn't do right yeah now JB I'll have
you do you think you've made more money
in wrestling or finance long term
finance no doubt about it yeah what do
you think a Bitcoin it's a bubble like
telling it's a modern-day tulipmania but
there's a there's a there's underlying
value in tulips they were back in the
1600s but it was a bubble I think it's a
bubble now I don't know where the
underlying value is but cryptocurrencies
are gonna take over governments hate
them so it's gonna be hard for these
cryptocurrencies to take over I would
not buy it because the government's
gonna try to suppress it because I think
they can't control it
right so most fiat currencies no matter
what it is start from the top down from
governments coming down this is gonna
have to start from the bottom up from
retail stores going up so it's going to
be a harder implementation but I think I
just I just have to Eric Bischoff and I
look at him I go I feel so stupid
you got any Bitcoin Bruce no ok no does
your show can I take bitcoins everybody
plays your show again no that's it box
of gimmicks calm you can get tickets
nice they don't take big Nick they take
American Express MasterCard Visa Diners
Club you know I'll take cash yeah can
you believe that that Bruce Prichard is
hosting a podcast absolutely the most
entertaining guys I've ever known but he
and Eric both I think they're both to
them who the best guys I've ever known
into the most entertaining guys have
ever known and to the most successful
but he was so big absolutely it's doing
a live show at the Barclays center they
do podcasts has always been entertaining
he's just being Bruce and there's a
reason he has a huge following I think
he's fantastic and I think most people
listen to him think the same thing yeah
the same thing about Erick yeah so so we
weren't done with the cryptocurrency
thing so I you think that it's one of
those things where hypothetically you
could see the logic in why
cryptocurrency would be a good thing but
governments will simply not try to
suppress it look at the big thing a
Bitcoin er initially was the Chinese
money that was stepping into it because
that way they can get money out of China
without the currency restrictions are
paying any type of fees and then it
became a speculative bubble I believe
but just because it's a bubble does not
mean there's not underlying value there
is underlying value he said you figure
out what that I gotta figure out where
it is I don't think it's $10,000 but I
don't know where it is that's a hundred
I don't know if it's 8000 I don't know
where it is right when did you get into
finance in the 97 Asian crisis I started
buying some money buying some stocks
when I first had some money well thanks
to Barrett getting me a new contract
about Applied Materials I think Oracle I
think it was the first couple stocks I
bought and they did really well like
everything did in late nineties and you
started studying and studying and
studying yeah I wrote a financial book
then after but say 2004 I wanted to
build a wind farm in West Texas where
I'm from it's the wind capital the world
worked with an investment bank the
renewable energy credit market imploded
so it killed the margins on the deal but
the Investment Banking liked what I did
and asked me to come work for them so I
work for an investment bank for about
three years on Wall Street Wow now a
wind farm is one of those deals where
they have all the like big deals and
stuff yeah and that's where I grew up
Sweetwater farming in Owen County is the
wind capital of the world
man now did you ever when you're a
performer and people know you is one
thing right they know use JBL or
Bradshaw from the Acolytes whatever they
know you as the wrestler that you're
portraying
do you want to kind of get out in front
everybody and say hey I've also know all
this stuff I'm not just this don't you
know that I don't know if that's
lack of ego or just a lack of
intelligence on my part but it's know I
look I loved what I did I love the
characters I've portrayed I love the
business I was in and still in and so I
enjoyed you know if they if they know
that I do other stuff that's great if
they don't that's fine as well I'd
rather people know about my charity work
and I started my own charity in Bermuda
and I worked with a lot of at-risk kids
I've been to India to the slums of
Mumbai just a couple months ago I'm
going to Haiti coming up we're gonna
Venezuela to work with a jail
ministry with at-risk kids and how to
work with education I'm working with
play rugby USA here in New York 5500
kids they've taken a graduation rates
from in some schools that are 50% to
100% with a hard percent going to
college other people talk about that
then the only thing I'd do is just fluff
so the roastmaster general Jeff Ross
just walked in let me let me explain
what you walked into oh I know JB oh hi
okay hi guys
Eric Bischoff who ran Debbie steady for
a long time then you worked at Dell UWE
for a long time and this is Bruce
Prichard who has the hottest the hottest
wrestling podcast honestly it's become
one of the hottest podcasts online and
he was one of Vince McMahon's right-hand
men for like 20 years so now he goes on
his podcast need for the role and you
know hi guys welcome to the Jim and Sam
Ross show I did a bit yesterday it's
gonna come out at the guns probably
tomorrow for the 25th Raw anniversary
did you yeah I'm gonna roast my favorite
heels of all time oh that's your current
heels are you a fan or did you go yeah
yeah
it's gonna be fun that's great one of
the tip one of the jokes yeah JBL on
your retirement uh congratulations my
favorite thing you ever announced was
your retirement that's pretty good my
quitting made you happy New York you
guys does it bother you that the shot
gets taken at the end would you rather
have the shot taking it you're
announcing or your wrestling look as a
matter what you wrestled no it's good to
see you guys
yeah I have a it's gonna be fun yeah Rob
Monday night I mean it's huge
everybody's in town this is so cool yeah
well you're you got a Caroline show yeah
all weekend right no I'm here I'm there
February 8th through 12th Oh have you so
what you doing here this weekend I'm not
I'm leaving this weekend for AMA coming
I'm not gonna pop up at the Comedy
Cellar this weekend but I'm in Europe
all week with Chris Rock that's that I'm
a surprise guest which I think I just
ruined that is
Oh two gigs and his Wembley gigs in
London all week our European listener
base is gonna be like what's up England
Glasgow and Nottingham and a bunch of
places in England this week and then I
come back to my home club Caroline's on
the whole February 8th February 8th 9 10
11 something like that so the weekend of
February 8 that's when Jeff Ross is
gonna be at Caroline's which is good
because then you don't have to compete
with Bruce Prichard at the Barclays
center so yeah I'm doing your podcast at
the Barclays amazing where do you get
tickets Bruce at boxing events calm
you're doing your podcast in a 20,000 C
venue yeah right after the basketball
game you got the basketball game and
then us right afterwards that's amazing
the double header so Wow and that's
tonight Bruce in the Barclays center
that is tonight at Barclays in our box
of gimmicks comments please get your
tickets gonna be our special guest Wow
Geoff come join us and uh JBL you know
and we've got an NBA game as a warm-up
act
yes you guys are dressed guys were
dressed for a podcast I always play
billiards and once in a while the three
ball yeah dressed as do stress testing
sainsbury Tony I got a I got a run up
bolt into a pro rugby team here in New
York City or in fact our game is March
24th I hate to promote something like
Bruce's so you find you what do you
think what do you think right bees gotta
do to break through here in the States
in a real real way I think rugby in the
United States is the greatest growth
opportunity in the globe the World Cup
2015 was the third most watched sporting
event of all time most more than the
Super Bowl so I think rugby is going to
happen in the United States now whether
we do it or not I'm not sure hopefully
we are the ones that do it but we've got
the the hottest market in New York and
we've got a team here in the new league
it kicks up CBS Sports is carrying our
game of the week I'll tell you if JBL is
is wrong about the things he's invested
in he makes you believe he's right for
sure stop it stop it you're the one is
the Barclays that are 20,000 seats for a
podcast you fly in from Bermuda to have
your toes done
toes done do you like my toes don't know
I'm a finger stuff yeah yeah just couple
generations away from all four so are
you making a big are you gonna be a
rough 25 with Ron Simmons yeah yes and
that'll be is that your first show back
since you've stepped away oh I did trip
to the troops of course but it's your
first traditional arena yes Monday Night
Raw show that one look fun that tribute
was awesome that was cool well I think
it's to me it's what the greatest thing
WB does every year is the tribute did
they shoot your cowboy hat off the you
can you earth can de Mille did I pretty
much just put it on the desk had more
actually in years nobody knows that
don't tell anybody
just a prop at this point well thank you
for thank you I appreciate it man you've
done a lot of stuff Richard oh yeah man
love doing troupe shows best audience
there is why is it just because they
don't they don't drink they want to see
the show that starved for entertainment
and their um and they're more diverse
and sophisticated than most audiences I
mean they're they're scientists you know
the military is all kinds of people yeah
great crowds do the troops come and
because people there are people who get
sensitive about the the insult brand of
humor right you know like they never
know especially well you don't wanna see
what JBL like when you when you were
firing shots at him I was like okay is
he gonna realize to assist he gonna
realize this is comedy or is fun but I'm
sure you run into that a lot well I only
roast people who look like they're game
look they're like they're up for it but
have you haven't you've been wrong every
now and then somebody gets man but not
too bad that's gay Bischoff looks fine
with it
I'm used to it brother and yes point
yeah you are good how long did it take
so like you're not well I guess yeah you
were always a TV guy but when you hit
that high profile that's when you got
people really criticizing you and the
audience becomes aware that you're
running the company so anything going
wrong with the company you're gonna get
criticized for anything they don't like
you on TV you're gonna get criticized
for at what point did you develop a
thick skin really when I started out you
know I I'm the beginning I came into the
industry with a lot of heat you know
part of it was because no one thought I
deserve to be in the fraternity I didn't
pay my dues I wasn't a wrestler I didn't
come up in a wrestling family all the
things that were kind of prerequisites
before I broke into the business and I
kind of looked like a Ken doll
weatherman so just the way I looked kind
of pissed people who got punched in the
face three hundred times it certainly
escalated as time went on and I was in
this weird spot you know we talked about
it earlier about heat and getting used
to he'd wanna heat I loved it because I
knew as long as the audience loved me my
checks would keep getting bigger excuse
me as long as I hated me they get big
keep getting bigger soon as I started
liking me I was in trouble right now did
you have you ever how are you when
you're not doing well on stage because
like I know Norton loves to so on some
level when he starts bombing no just
because you know you've been doing it
for so long he's like I'm gonna enjoy
this I'm gonna make the audience like
pay for this a little bit you know I I
don't know I don't or do you get a D at
awkward I think people kind of like Jeff
Ross show they're expecting like to get
made fun of they're expecting me to rip
in and if it's my show like it
Caroline's it's my crowd coming to see
me it's gonna be foolproof I don't feel
like it'll be bad the only thing that
can go wrong is if someone's drunk or
heckling
right you don't get people that like
because I feel like because you have
this thing that you do and people are
gonna people think that they can do it
too
like people think that the stuff we do
on the radio like if Norton and me are
insulting each other right
we're gonna get that from people on
Twitter because they're like hey we're
all doing it and I get it but it's like
it's not the same so League I was
totally bad when it's not on state when
it's not in the club like if I walk into
the airport but you don't mind those
things like controlled you know you have
to do it in the right context and if
people figured out that like this is the
thing that you do it's not like you come
to a row so we can all make fun of each
other like some of you guys are the
audience yeah right yeah that's exactly
it yeah and then you know in a weird way
when I roast somebody like if I'm
roasting Justin Bieber I'm doing it
vicariously for you know the entire
world so in a weird way they want me to
sort
free-range right right don't get in my
way if anything like if if a word leaks
out that I'm roasting somebody everyone
I come in contact with even like cab
drivers and people on the street will
start giving me material on that person
really this is about Bieber or whatever
do you ever use it oh yeah really
that's great it's good for ideas yeah
I'm not saying anybody is a good joke
right or randomly on the street but
it'll start you yeah in the direction
yeah were you there for the half Hugh
Hefner roast oh yeah yeah I produce that
one right so I was white the reason it
was just in my head was because I just
watched the Gilbert Godfried
documentaries great Gilbert is a his
Gilbert's joke what his 9/11 joke yeah
now that some time has passed I think we
can all recognize it as one of these
great roast jokes like it's just an
incredible joke but in that moment like
it just fell completely flat as a do you
like seeing guy like Gilbert cuz you
know that the joke is good so it's not
like this is a reflection on Gilbert do
you like that uncomfortable moment or do
you sit there like oh when they save
Gilbert it was a it was a night I mean
it was a month of uncomfortableness you
know yes 911 in New York and we were
honoring Hugh Hefner who's like the
reason two terrorists hate us
[Laughter]
sexuality freedom and and you know I
remember writing a letter like a few
days after 9/11 cuz we had to decide
whether it were the show's gonna go on
or not because we had you know a hotel
booked and TV trucks and it was a big
commitment yeah and my my position was
and I made this known to Hef in the
Comedy Central and to the Friars Club
that if we don't go on with the show
that literally is the terrorists winning
and that wasn't cliche back then it had
just happened 9/11 yeah and New Yorkers
were still sort of covering their mouths
and trying to breathe and I was like you
know it's three weeks away and I
actually think we should just cancel the
after-party give the money into the Twin
Towers Fund and do this show yeah and
the roast must go on and there were a
lot of uncomfortable moments I think the
first one was Rob Schneider was doing
well and
he hit a few wrong notes and I ran up to
him and I put my arm around him and I
said Rob hasn't been enough bombing in
this where you know Jimmy Kimmel was
hosting and he he actually set the tone
really well right at the top and yeah
by the time Gilbert got on nobody had
really gone for a to the gut 9/11 planes
into buildings everybody knows so the
Joe Barry the roast Gilbert Gilbert goes
up and he said I'm probably gonna
butcher it for so forgive me but he goes
there in New York and he's like I've
been trying to catch and he's obviously
shouting it cuz he's Gilbert Godfried so
it's just like if it's a gut punch it's
a gut punch he goes I'm in New York and
I keep trying to get a direct flight out
of here but I can't get a flight without
a layover in the Empire State Building
this is a month after 9/11 yeah so the
room just died someone yelled too soon
it was like the first time you really
heard it too soon and that's when
Gilbert like said okay and he took a
second to collect himself and then he
did the he did a version of the
aristocrats joke which is the filthiest
you know pedophile incest like just like
okay well if that's too much let me give
you every taboo thing in one joke and
that's where we'll leave it and by the
end of the horrible you know aristocrats
joke the crowd is right back with him he
got them all back it was amazing
well it was really amazing he is a force
to be reckoned with yeah do you think
he's one of the is he one of the best in
a situation like that
well he's the most entertaining ya know
if I was running a diabetes charity he
might not be the I'm trying to break
through people's tension and pain during
a national crisis I think Gilbert is the
right medicine he's the guy to call yeah
I mean that's what a comedy is more than
ever right now right like you notice
like all the comedy clubs are packed all
our friends are doing so well because I
don't know people are in uncertain times
they look to the comedians to tell the
truth to make them feel better and to be
an escape right and the Venus
get from your normal shitty life which I
mean it's same role wrestling please
isn't it we try to yeah yeah we tried to
although sometimes laugh you guys just
throw so much [ __ ] at the wall that you
were like why the [ __ ] would you do that
yeah pretty much
by the way I'll tell you something else
about Bruce Prichard that we're about to
run out of time but I should have
mentioned it first of all of course
he'll be at the Barclays tonight at
boxing gimmicks calm is where you get
tickets and Eric Bischoff will be with
them Jeff Ross is gonna be at Caroline's
weekend of February 8th but P Diddy
stole his name brother love and this
podcast has gotten so big that P Diddy
got inundated with tweets and it
comments and all this stuff you're kind
of curb stomp P did you pretty much put
it into that how does that feel you beat
P Diddy it was great you know and he he
backed down he tapped out and did his
whole you know I'm not really I was just
kidding so on and so forth in his
management called to say hey just ask
Bruce to be kind how's it I didn't do
anything it was just it was just our
audience that just hammered him
unmercifully
so you hadn't mentioned it yet oh I sent
out one tweet saying there's only one
brother loved and that's me I'm the
original and I've known him since 1993
and he pretended like he didn't know who
I was on well come on man
you know we've hung out at drinks so
yeah he tapped out pretty quick Wow it
was great it was pretty neat it's a
great victory that was that's a great
victory it really is because you if
there was another roast if did he like
well got one he's like I'm the
roastmaster general
[Laughter]